hey there i'm phil molina and this is a
breakdown of this season finale of Game
of Thrones it's season 6 episode 10 the
winds of winter and now while we did
predict some of the things that we're
gonna happen in this episode that didn't
make them any less shocking and honestly
for me the biggest surprise of all is
just how good this episode was
considering how amazing the last episode
was it's really rare to get two in a row
like this and as of right now both of
these episodes have a perfect 10 on IMDB
and I don't think it's a coincidence
that they were both directed by the
amazing Miguel Zapata Nick alright so
sit back and relax because we've got a
lot of analysis and missable details to
talk about this was the longest episodes
of Game of Thrones ever and with good
reason so much happens but seriously
that means that this is going to be huge
so let's just go ahead and get started
with the opening images actually though
ahead of the images let's quickly
address what we hear over these images
it's the sound of the huge Bell that
hangs over the great set ringing fer as
it turns out the very last time now this
Bell has always been paired with some
bad times for our characters and having
marked the death of various Lannisters
it's definitely a sound that is haunted
Cersei will come back to the Bell later
but let's talk about what we're seeing
here following up the epic scale of the
Battle of the bastards the director
chose to actually scale things way way
down to a very small personal level
paying meticulous detail to the
simplicity of each of them getting ready
he does this to really underline each of
these characters as individual people
know how at this point we don't even see
the faces of their helpers they're all
effectively alone right now and that is
gonna make it hit that much harder when
we see what becomes of each of these
people later in the episode we're not
just gonna see a big group of deaths
we're gonna feel each one as a single
loss now this move this focusing on the
minutia of preparations in a show as
epic as Game of Thrones it's actually
becoming a director trademark for this
guy this directors directed four
episodes of this show and they often
open this way just really scale down
this season he directed battle the
Basterds and this episode the winds of
winter and he starts with that focus on
the small mechanics of what's about to
happen and then last season he directed
hardhome and the gift and you can see
how the
gift also opens with the simplicity's of
preparation and actually now is a good
time to explain a really special
relationship between these two episodes
so last season's hardhome is a pretty
obvious sister episode to this season's
Battle of the bastards they're both
about Jon Snow and his men being
completely devastated in battle against
their former allies turned enemies but
actually the other pair of episodes this
season finale and last season's the gift
they're also very much sister episodes
to in fact they're more linked than
probably any pair of episodes the shows
of her hat so this episode is all about
how we're finally seen the changing of
the seasons and with that we get all the
setups and promises finally being paid
off so this episode is about the
fulfillment of those promises the gift
is the episode that set up those ideas
we'll get into the links of these two
sister episodes more as we go but let's
just call it right now this is a posh
net guys director he's a genius okay now
before we move on completely from the
opening images let's quickly point out a
few things here first it's important to
realize that everyone is getting ready
for most of the sequence but when you
look at Cersei she's already dressed
that's pointing out to us that while
each of these people is just beginning
to plan for their day Circe's plans have
already long been in motion and now
she's waiting for everyone to catch up
to her and this outfit is clearly a
feminine power outfit that's inspired by
the powerful leather attire that was
once worn by Tywin Lannister
just like how Jaime recently stepped
into the Tywin role but kind of hated it
Cersei is trying on the role of head of
House Lannister but she actually loves
it
then once everyone is in place Cersei
finally chooses to dawn one more layer
armor she's not going to trial she's
going to war this is a nice callback
actually to the first season when Cersei
suggests she'd make a better ruler than
Robert I should wear the armor and use a
cow and as we prepare to transition to
the trial itself I'll point out how this
version of trial with seven high septons
is something that hasn't been done in
hundreds of years and while it feels
like we just learned about it a few
episodes ago this actually was first set
up in the gift the trial will be held
for each
to determine if they're guilty of any
acts that might constitute a violation
of the tenets of the faith he'll stand
judge certain septums but it's not just
being set up in that scene
the high Sparrow actually foreshadows
what's gonna happen to every person
there and to the great Sept of Baelor
itself listen closely
Baelor built his scepter on it that
great guilty monstrosity up there strip
away the gold the ornaments knock down
the statues and the pillars the Tyrells
finery will be stripped away their lies
knocked down their true hearts laid bare
for all to see that's how it will be for
all of us well yeah all of those things
are definitely stripped away himself
included but it's funny because as it's
happening
he's totally blind to the event itself
until it's too late
remember how few episodes back a shot of
a sewer grate was used to remind us
about these tunnels beneath the city
and what Cersei could do with them well
our first shot inside the great set
concludes that setup by aiming down
directly over the sewer grate that leads
below the set and the high Sparrow being
totally clueless to that danger that's
beneath him it's emphasized again and
again in these later shots where he
keeps being seen from below but he's
only concerned what is up above him the
guards he's paying attention to the
wrong direction and this being unaware
of the danger that awaits it's not just
the cinematography communicating this
this amazing amazing score
plays a big role in telling the story -
now before we dive into how it does that
I want to point out something
interesting here this is the first time
we've heard piano as the lead instrument
in Game of Thrones which normally uses
strings and percussion piano happens to
be a fairly modern instrument invented
somewhere around 1700 meanwhile we're
used to a score that matches the Middle
Ages which is the time that we usually
equate with the show so this choice to
use piano is another one of these
markers in this episode that signifies a
modernization changing of the seasons
out with the old in with the new
and again that's a major theme of this
episode but ok I want to dive into just
how masterful this piece of music was
but because I know I'm about to nerd out
about music theory and that might not be
up all of your alleys I here's the time
to skip to if you don't care about the
role music plays in storytelling cool
all right great
ok so first off I want to point out that
music was creating unease before the
episode even started I don't know if you
all notice but the previously on game of
Thrones sex room was very different than
usual it started with music rather than
dialogue
and just as it finishes right before we
launch into the episode the composer
chose to strike a discordant note this
starts us off balance right away kind of
like climbing an old staircase and you
catch you foot on the very last step it
starts you off uneasy then as the music
plays over the sequence it actually
tells the story as it unfolds by adding
musical layering each moment characters
come closer to danger and ultimately
their deaths
watch check it out the moment was shown
the set the score kicks in but with
extreme restraint just an incredibly
simple piano melody everyone walks in
clueless and then as the intended
victims the Terrell's the high Sparrow
they begin to take their place a layer
of strings comes in signifying that
they're a layer closer to danger but
then we switch to pycelle who has not at
all stepped into danger yet and does
some music pulls back again removing a
layer and it's just a simple piano again
Tommen also has no understanding of
what's happening yet and so we stay in
that simple piano
bris been Lancel and pycelle alternate
but still don't know anything yet and so
everything remains in piano that is
until the very moment that pycelle sees
Khyber
now he's thrown out of rhythm and so is
the music right then it strikes an
awkward pair of notes for this awkward
encounter so it's clear something is up
now as Lancel and pycelle grow one layer
closer to their deaths
a musical layers added the singing of
two boys representing the little birds
who will cause the deaths of these two
characters when pycelle becomes aware
getting his final sign seeing the knife
before him the final warning layer of
strings is added and then right when
death has arrived a new instrument often
associated with death a layer of pipe
organ is added
but then we cut back to Lancel and we
lose a lot of the layers because he's
not as far along in his danger yet that
is until Oh dad that leads to his death
triggers the layers coming back in
including that death
pipe organ layer and here it's much more
obvious than before that organ is
playing the main game of Thrones theme
song reminding us that this is what
happens to characters that get mixed up
in the great game and yet again just as
we return to the steppe the layers are
pulled back again we're back to simple
piano because everyone here is clueless
of the impending danger it's here that
I'm gonna point out that the other
reason piano was used because when you
strike a piano key it's really unique
and how it has a very powerful attack
striking quickly and sharply but then it
resonates with a long decay and this is
subconsciously similar to the attack and
decay of a warning alarm some moments
later Margaery starts to put it all
together so cue the layer of warning
strings when she encounters the high
Sparrow who is still totally clueless
the strings pull back again but if she
makes her case they start to swell back
in again and from this point on
everybody's been warned so the strings
do not leave again and then when Lancel
finally sees the wildfire time bomb he
gets it and our death organ kicks in
he's looking death in the face and as we
alternate between Lancel and the shots
inside the set the organ alternates with
it louder and quieter louder in quiet
ah
and then everyone in the set realizes
fully not only did the organ come back
in full force but a new and final layer
of strings
and like how the striking of the piano
keys were reminiscent to the chimes of a
warning siren these final strings are
meant to be the old-world equivalent of
the beeping of a time bomb they
countdown the very last seconds adding
that last bit of intense tension until
the very last second and the music cuts
out they give over the entirety of the
full sound spectrum to the explosion
letting us experience it as close to the
real thing as possible so that's er a
brilliantly composed piece of music
unlike anything we've heard on this show
but perfectly match to the events that
were unfolding it's cool all right let's
go ahead and move on and rejoin the
people who skipped ahead because they
hate music now before we leave these
moments leading up to the big freaking
explosion I've got to point out a few
more things here first Qyburn hits one
of our themes about seasons changing
right on the head as he says but some
times before we can usher in the new the
own ostrich was erased so just as in
when the fall season is ending winter
begins that same winter lays waste to
all the old-growth that came before his
words are also reflected visually by
what happens the new children put the
old man to rest also Quickbook spoiler
here it's it's really quick actually so
you can just cover your ears if you
don't want to know but in the books
none of this blowing up the steppe stuff
has happened yet but the last thing we
see in the last published book is
actually this murder by the little birds
but it's not pycelle they're killing
it's Kevan Lannister and the person
behind it strangely enough it's not
Qyburn it's Varys okay book spoilers
over you can come back oh and I have to
say I loved the use of candles as like
an ancient time bomb I got a message on
my facebook page from Roselia Mendoza
and it really clicked with me about
these candles they're a nice
representation of the opening sequence
itself but also of this entire season
with the show methodically getting ready
at the beginning and all the episodes
leading up to the Battle of the bastards
you could have kind of described all
this as a slow burn little did we know
what kind of explosive moments were in
store for us once the season long candle
reached its end two episodes of just
full-out
spectacular chaos oh also unrelated I
have to say this little kid here is the
one that
those candles he's got tremendous balls
like elephant balls moving on there's
also this great but quickly miscible
moment in the set when Marjorie shouts
at the high Sparrow the truth finally
comes out again about the bloody goats
and isn't what I'm telling you it was
all an act a religious zealot would
either listen to the sparrow or be eager
to die for her faith like panella and
the sparrow claimed to be instead she's
like yeah f this faith thing let's get
out of here and that is why the high
Sparrow looks so shocked he had totally
fallen for her act and poor Marjorie she
deserves a special shout-out because she
did piece this whole thing together
before anyone else and her ability to do
that actually was also set up nicely in
the gift there Marjorie reveals that
she's really good at piecing together
when Cersei is up to something I know
you did she just wasn't fast enough here
and in that very same scene from the
gift it has a bit of foreshadowing of
what will become of Cersei as we know
now she's done with the Mad King had
always planned to do and so it's fair to
say that this episode she's officially
become the Mad Queen and if you remember
the beginning of this season Cersei
feels as if she's a prisoner being kept
in a Cell in the red key she would like
you to remain in the red cape your grace
dear you have been confined to the red
key well back in the scene from the gift
check out what word she use it's
described what happens to someone when
they're kept in a Cell in the red cape
I've been told men often go mad in the
black cells beneath the red keep she was
right it drove her mad oh and again in
terms of this episode moments after
Circe says that line is when she
discovers that Lancel had betrayed her
and confessed what they did together
resulting in Cersei being in prison in
the first place so that set up him
metaphorically stabbing her in the back
is paid off in this episode with her
planning to have him stabbed in the bank
all right so that's everything leading
up to the explosion and if you feel like
this a lot I'm gonna point out it may
not have felt like it but the explosion
was around 20 minutes into the episode
even though it feels like it happened
right at the beginning but after the
explosion we get Cersei taken into sight
with her hair blowing back from the
shock wave and wind's making a blast
feel on level with like a freaking nuke
and there's the bell that I said I was
going to come back to which has now been
defeated by Cersei as well it can't ever
deliver bad news to her again of course
that doesn't stop that stuff from
happening as we see in a second with
Tommen and it's
that actually that that's a king dying
and the bells not ever gonna ring for
him but we'll get back to Tommen in a
second it's Circe's happiness here that
we really need to focus on we've talked
before about how Game of Thrones is
inspired by our real history and we've
also talked about how King's Landing is
the Westerosi version of ancient Rome
this moment would sir see it parallels
the famous story of Nero watching on his
Rome burn I know a lot of you might have
heard that he was playing a fiddle but
he probably wasn't because the fiddle
wasn't invented yet but there actually
are a lot of stories of people saying
exactly what he did do a number of
accounts at least claim that he just
watched from a safe distance
some say he was up in a tower watching
just like Cersei and some people even
think that he deliberately wanted that
part of the city destroyed just like she
did because he later went on to build
his golden palace and his pleasure
gardens there but if we stick with how
Nero played things we can also make one
possible prediction for season seven
well it's really obvious that Cersei
caused this explosion I wouldn't be
surprised if the official stance will be
that this was some sort of attack on the
faith by some radical sect of another
religion and I say that not only because
it kind of makes sense as an excuse but
because that's the same excuse Nero came
up with not that people believed him
either but in his day he claimed that
the fire must have been caused by crazy
followers of that radical new religion
known as Christianity and I've said this
before but the Westerosi equivalent of
Christians they're the followers of the
Lord of Light so maybe search they will
blame the attack on the faith of the
seven as having been a strategic move by
the Lord of Light followers but here's
the thing the faith of the seven is
about to hit a major roadblock not only
was it completely wiped out at King's
Landing but remember that there were
seven high septons there meaning that
other than the high Sparrow six other
major leaders of that religion have also
now been taken out so if the Lord of
Light religion did want to make their
move even though they technically had
nothing to do with this attack now would
be a good time of course that wouldn't
be that good for Cersei either
considering the two people that the high
ups of that religion are worshipping at
this moment aren't exactly her biggest
fans and I think we can all agree that
in the long term this grand scheme of
Circe's it's only gonna provide her
maybe a little win for now and is
actually gonna result in her building
more enemies but for now her most
immediate challengers are gone and she
is in power and it's all of those
circumstances that make this entire
a big old reference to the Godfather in
that movie during another very
religiously significant moment a baptism
in a church Michael Corleone has his men
secretly execute all of his family's
challenges simultaneously and their
deaths are also indicated by an intense
organ score and like I said I think sir
Steve will absolutely pay for this a
little later we're gonna talk about how
the gods react to things like this but
I'll point out here that I think the
high Sparrow is foreshadowing something
that will actually probably happen with
this line the warrior punishes those who
believe themselves beyond the reach of
justice the warrior is gonna come for
Cersei but who's that we're gonna be
Dany maybe or Jaime but okay now let's
go ahead and talk about poor poor Tommen
Baratheon the rest in peace and on kids
day no host but we're actually gonna use
this really cool visual segue the show
used to transition to this we start out
with Circe's view of the destruction and
this really slick reference to the line
that keeps getting thrown in her face
about how crown and the fate of the twin
pillars upon which the world rests and
there are twin pillars and that shot of
the representation of the faith
demolished it cuts to the representation
of the crown Tommen also falling apart
but here's what's really interesting the
editing made us think that this was also
Tommen's perspective on the scene but as
we see momentarily it's not this is
Tommy's view and this shot here is
actually very different
the director stays in the shot to make
this moment that happens more surprising
sure but also it shows us exactly how
Tommen sees what just happened his
perspective compared to Circe's is much
more blocked off looking at this site
being locked into this view it makes the
audience and Tom and see clearly that
there's only one way out through the
window and this fall is a payoff of the
setup from the pilot where Tom ins real
father Jaime forced this kind of fall
under brand it kicked off the whole
story but now it comes back to their
family but way worse man the things that
this family does for love I put it now
it also though is paying off a set up
from the episode the gift it's a couple
of moments actually so in our current
episode Tommen sees that he's lost his
queen and lost his faith all
same moment and seeing alternatives he
goes out the window and the gift Tommen
is upset that the queen is in prison and
there is nothing I can do
seeing no alternatives he gets lost
gazing out a window its Cersei that has
to pull him back from it and there while
she tries to console him she gives us
that foreshadowing line about what she
did this episode I would do anything for
you anything to keep you from home I
would burn cities to the ground except
in this episode while she does burn a
city to the ground
it's for her own selfish reason not to
keep him from harm
in fact she's not there to keep him from
harm when he goes to the window this
time and that episode reiterates this
point multiple times when Cersei tells
Elena that and when she tells Margaery
that she must go I'm afraid I must my
son needs me now yet when he really
needs her most and Margaery isn't just
in a Cell she's dead instead of going to
be by his side to comfort him she
instead heads off to gleefully torture
septa unella and since we are talking
about both episodes right now let's go
ahead and point out another completion
of a setup
since the gift is the episode where
Cersei is first taken by own Ella and
makes that threat that she references
this episode look at my face is the last
thing you see before you die
here's what's really cool actually when
she leaves in Ella behind screaming it's
even shot exactly the same way with the
doorway in its window showing us the
inside one last time before it's closed
off now there is probably a lot more to
say about this creepy and pretty evil in
Ella's scene here but we've got so much
more to cover and I think we should just
move on you can hit me up separately if
you want to discuss it further for now
let's just move on to the red wedding
part - honeymoon part and it's really
interesting to rewatch these scenes
knowing that aria is there the whole
time she stares at Jamie for a bit which
they read is flirting but knowing it's
Aria it feels more sinister she probably
is actually considering whether or not
she should kill him but she chooses to
spare him since he's not really on her
list that said he probably would be on
her list if she knew he was the one that
pushed bran out that window fun little
thing to point out by the way when
Walder Frey asks shocks mock me where
they though there's one right there
that's Aria passing by in the background
unbeknownst to him by the way it's
pretty clever how are you chose to make
her way into this place she's purposely
using a skill that she's had a lot of
practice with serving as a cup bearer to
a prominent Lord remember her in
Thailand and she was hiding her identity
that time too the only thing about that
though is that she doesn't entirely
remember all of the trainings you got
there or she purposely wanted Walter to
know that something was up because check
out this warning that Tywin gives her
about the way she addresses him go
milord
no boom girls say milord not my lord if
you're gonna pose as a commoner you
should do it properly and yet here she
makes the same mistake again you're not
one of mine are you no my lord I don't
my lord but again it could be on purpose
and then we have the pie and this is a
twist from a similar event in the books
where the manderlys actually make the
pie and they feed it to the Bolton's and
honestly I like this version better
making it Arya who does this gives a
real nice justification of where she got
this idea from because she learned it
from old nan and the tales that she used
to tell the stark children and we know
that because bran who often recounts old
man's tales tells us about this tale of
the rat cook a few seasons ago and this
is actually the same night as a red
wedding the cook killed the king's son
cooked him into a big pie that night he
served the pie to the king like the
taste of his son so much he asked her
second slice the gods turned the cook
into a giant white rat who could only
eat his own young it's been roaming the
Nightfort ever since I'm entranced Ori
has to do with the punishment for
violating guests rights resident for
murder the gods cursed the rat cook all
for serving the king's son in a pot he
killed a guest beneath his roof that's
something the gods can't forget so this
moment now is finally payback for this
huge violation of guests rights that
Walder Frey made back in the red wedding
but here's a thought something I touched
on earlier actually if the gods take a
violation of guests rights this
seriously and this is the level of
punishment they deliver what are the
gods think when you destroy their main
house of worship and kill all the people
inside I mean since bran is referring to
the old gods in the Sept of Baelor is
about the new gods I think Cersei just
better hope that the seven are a lot
more chill than the old gods are and
just two final points to make here about
this story at the twins first we hear
what are probably the words of house
pray at the beginning it's not for sure
that those are words but it definitely
seems like it and that's actually a big
deal because that's the first time we've
ever heard them ever including in the
books so now we know that House Frey is
all about standing together and loyalty
sure house prayed you believe whatever
you want the other thing to point out is
that with Walder Frey's throat being
slashed all the main perpetrators of the
events of the red wedding Walder Frey
Roose Bolton and Tywin Lannister they've
now been killed in the same way that the
Starks were killed at the red wedding
stabbed in the gut shot with the
crossbow and having her throat slit
karma can be so tidy okay let's move on
to Cersei checking out Tommy's body oh
great there's no need show me I only
want to point out two things here
actually first Cersei wanting to see
Tommy's body after it's fallen from
however high up it's actually a little
bit of a callback to her as a child
wanting to know what her mother's corpse
looks like after she's died do you
remember the first time you saw a dead
body
mother well I can think about when she
died was what would happen to
now every day every night what is mamala
like now and also wondering the same
with Marcela you think about locking
Marcela in a crypt think about her
beautiful little face starting to she's
kind of into corpses and second Cersei
mentioned that Tommen should be laid to
rest where his brother sister and
grandfather are he should be with his
grandfather his brother his sister burn
him
berries ashes with a Sept one stood that
means that the remains of her children
and her father were also at the Sept of
Baelor and yet that did not stop her
from blowing it up it further cements
that Cersei has no patience for death
she doesn't care about what happens
after she's even denying Tom and a
funeral here it explains why she acts
the way she does she probably doesn't
even believe in any of the gods and she
feels that her only chance at happiness
and success is here in this life now she
doesn't care about any sort of
punishment in the afterlife
it makes her way more dangerous because
she truly has nothing to fear now okay
and now we are off to Old Town and we
start this with a really pretty shot
where we see all these white Ravens
flying out the Citadel tower these white
Ravens are only sent out when a new
season has officially been declared so
this is a visual representation of that
episode long theme of promises delivered
and seasons changing ironically we see
one of these go to Winterfell as if they
didn't already know that winter has come
and then when sam meets this sassy
Citadel receptionist i karin mclean on
my facebook page pointed out that it's
very possibly a reference to this scene
in the movie brazil she's probably right
because we've got another character here
named Sam who just so happens to be
played by the high Sparrow himself
Jonathan Pryce and he's entering into
this very similar very big hall with
another tight-lipped receptionist and
endless records await him there too and
that movie also has some fun weird
magnifying glasses and now when we gain
access to the internal Citadel library
this is all pretty beautiful and while a
lot of you probably caught this one I
got to point out how cool it is to
finally see what looks to be maybe the
exact same astrolabe from the opening
even the inscriptions look the same and
I want to go into theory time to discuss
what exactly this might be telling us
and actually you know what it's the end
of the season and this is
pretty weird but fun idea so what the
hell let's make it another instance of
really out there theory time okay
welcome to really out there theory time
so this ash lab that is from the opening
credits and we now see where it really
lives I think that just put this entire
series into context for us the events of
Game of Thrones the TV show lease from
the Royals visiting Winterfell in the
pilot to however this whole thing is
going to end are either all in the
process of being recorded as part of the
official written record of the history
of Westeros by a maester in the Citadel
maybe even Sam himself or they're being
studied by a future student in the
Citadel who is reading along as we watch
it here's why I think this the opening
credits show the Citadel astrolabe
hanging high up over this map the map
itself is constantly being updated and
changed both in terms of what places we
need to focus on but also even who holds
that location like the Bolton's or the
Starks or also what season were even in
with winner a lot of the map became
frozen over recently so let's say it's
Sam doing this and he's writing this
story down and consistently he's
redrawing out the map as part of his
records and maybe this map is actually a
very small drawing like on the corner of
a page and in order to edit it he needs
to wear magnifying lenses like the ones
the other Meister was wearing and like
the lenses that magnify the map in the
opening credits cool right so maybe Sam
is the guy that's writing this entire
story like the Song of Ice and Fire
itself and that would make him a
representation of george RR martin
himself it definitely would explain how
sam goes to bravely kill a white Walker
and then totally gets laid but alright
let's uh let's go ahead and jump out of
really out there theory time the only
two other things to point out about this
visit here first that astral ape thing
has one more really cool property it
seems like all these chains can be
pulled to reflect sunlight to the
various dark points of the library which
is smart because too many candles in
that place could easily cause the green
trial part to but the other thing I want
to point out here is why Sam is even
here I mean we technically know this
already but it's worth reminding us he's
on a mission to learn whatever he can to
help defeat the white Walker army and
while it's not the most exciting story
right now
it could become invaluable later and a
lot of long-lost secrets are locked away
in this place so Sam could learn how to
create more dragonglass which kills
white walkers or he does have heart's
pain with him maybe he's gonna learn
from these books how to create Valyrian
steel which is a long lost art form and
it also makes White Walkers not feel too
good
and finally this one's a little bit out
there but a lot of masters try to learn
one more thing here it's magic and a lot
of them fail to learn it but what if Sam
could learn the ways of magic like those
Warlocks of Qarth or Qyburn
I'd be pretty cool you're a wizard Sam I
always wanted to be a wizard okay so
that's it for old town and before we
move on now it's a good time to just say
thank you to everyone who was signed up
to help us out on patreon I am forever
grateful for your support and as more of
you keep signing up and helping us glass
through our goals like you have been
already I'm getting more and more
excited for what this channel is gonna
become we're gonna keep scaling up and
not only our videos gonna come out
faster as we can afford to hire
full-time editors and finally pay Kyllo
actually but we're also good to be able
to do way more videos about way more
topics so if you have another chance
check it out just go ahead it's
patreon.com slash new rockstars look at
the goals and the rewards that you would
get but in general yes thank you so much
we sincerely appreciate it thank you but
also I need to go to the bathroom really
bad so stay right there I've been
holding this this whole breakdown but I
promise I will be right back I promise
I'll pay it off later we'll jump in a
winterfell beer bank and we're back
promises fulfilled and we are in
Winterfell with the showdown between
Davos and Melisandre then we've been
waiting for all season and I've got to
admit I'm a little surprised that Davos
let Mellie leave this place alive her
burning Shireen is probably one of the
most disgusting things we've ever seen
any character on the show do which is
saying a lot by the way the idea to burn
Shireen so the setup for this moment
that we're seeing now it's also from the
gift I have shown you the power of Kings
blood
we don't have Roberts bastard here no we
have someone better and your blood runs
through her veins
but anyway other things to point out
here first I think there's a little bit
more meaning to this charred stag then
it just being the evidence for Davos to
catch up to what's happened with the
stag beam vestigial for house baratheon
seeing this burnt little figurine it
actually symbolizes what's happened in
this episode technically speaking with
Thomas death today the bracken line has
been totally wiped out it's burned and
done so that's pretty huge actually and
we'll get into the idea of who the
throne is technically supposed to go to
later but I'll just point out that if
you follow the Baratheon line upward
from Tommen it goes to his older male
sibling who's dead then their father who
is dead then to his father's male
siblings who are also dead then you
start going to grandparents and that's
where things get interesting but we'll
talk about that when we get to the Iron
Throne later also I just want to point
out this debate that dadless Melisandre
have it's actually pretty fascinating
they're both totally right like I agree
with Davos that any god that wants you
to burn a little girl alive is probably
a bad god you burnt a little girl alive
I only do what my lord cannot commands
you to burn children your Lord is evil
but Melisandre is holy right - when she
points out that the Lord of Light
brought dawn back that's the only reason
they're even standing there we are
standing here because of him
Jon Snow is alive because the Lord
willed it so if you're happy that Jon's
back you can't totally hate that Lord I
genuinely don't know where I stand on
the Lord of Light right now tell me what
you guys think in the comments below
keep going oh and onto this conversation
outside with Jon and Sansa so this again
hits us right in the face with these
themes this moment actually connects our
two main ones promises are being
fulfilled and seasons are changing the
long waiting promise of the season of
winter coming it's now being fulfilled
winter is here the winds of winter are
basically hitting a smack in the face
right now
I joked earlier that this is probably
the one place that maybe didn't need a
raven because they all know that winter
is here and they've known that since the
day that the snow came and never stopped
coming by the way that day was depicted
in the other episode they get Sweta is
coming those aren't just the stark words
that's a fact I want to point out
something here about the roles that
Sansa and Jon are playing right now it's
pretty clear that jon is very much a Ned
Stark surrogate he does what is right
and honorable even if it's gonna hurt
him
we'll watch Sansa is a little bit more
cunning and she suggests that only food
trusted yeah well she doesn't mean for
that to be an insult to him but Ned
Stark made that same mistake I just
warned you not to trust me
and it's maybe the biggest example of
someone falling for a little finger trap
so since John is filling that Ned role
now it makes me wonder is he gonna make
the same mistake he hasn't been great
about heating Sansa's advice so is he
gonna walk right into a little finger
trap himself oh and just before we move
on I wonder where Melisandre is heading
we know she has to ride south and we
also know that the Brotherhood without
banners they're riding north so could
they intercept each other the main
reason why that might be interesting is
because of arya actually a way back when
the red woman said this to her we will
meet again I mean that scene Arya is
very pissed that Thoreau's and beric
Dondarrion just sold her buddy Gendry to
Melisandre she's so pissed that she
actually puts all three of them on her
list the red woman
beric Dondarrion the rest of man so if
they all happen to go to the same place
and meet up and with Arya now back in
Westeros crossing names off her list
could this be a perfect storm of
characters meeting next season we will
have to wait and see obviously but one
weird thing is that Arya didn't actually
mention these same names on a recent
reciting of her list
Lucy Nonna's dude
Griego cocaine vulgar frame so she might
be up in the air about whether or not
she still wants these people dead and
now we're off to Dorne for the first
time since the season premiere we won't
stay long though because I only want to
point out a few quick things first when
Lady Olenna explains that she's got
nothing left yes she's still the future
from me with the fall of her house it
actually concludes something that she's
set up in the gift I promise you Lord
Baelish that our fates are joined
together we murdered a king if my house
should fall I will have nothing to hide
and if she lives up to her promise it
could throw a wrench into Littlefinger's
plans so she's got nothing to lose is
she gonna go out and tell everyone that
Littlefinger helped kill Joffrey I mean
she doesn't care about herself she's got
nothing to lose now and that certainly
would blindside him especially since he
was hoping to work with Cersei who's
just promised him warden of the North
name me warden of the north
if he took out Ramsay Bolton which he
just did next did you notice the way
that Ilario calls out Varys ringing a
little bell what the hell is that that
seems so rude I think the reason we see
Lady Olenna smirk is because that's her
move she calls me wild little bells but
she has a really good reason she's super
old and has bad hips ilaria is maybe
doing that as like a Power Move or
something but to Lady Olenna it just
makes her look weak like older than her
years but anyway the real meat of this
is when beerus comes out and reveals to
Elena that she can deliver her vengeance
in the form of fine blood I'm sure a lot
of you caught that since you're all huge
fans but in case you didn't those are
the words of House Targaryen
and speaking of house bloody fire let's
jump to marine so we've got this really
awkward breakup scene between Danny and
Daario and it's interesting that the
emotions of the scene are actually
totally undercut a moment later when
Danny reveals that she didn't feel
anything while she was talking to him
and I felt nothing when Danny is scared
of what that means it's cuz she's
wondering is she unable to love anyone
as much as she loves the idea of taking
the Iron Throne and that fear her being
afraid of who she might be
that's exactly who's Cersei Lannister
currently is she barely feels anything
when her son has died because it's given
her the throne and later when it seems
like the throne might have cost her her
big love
Jamie she doesn't really seem to care
there either all so quickly point out
that this dario frustration isn't as out
of nowhere as it sounds
are you a queen of fish bait I can't
bring a lover to Westeros a king
wouldn't think twice about it so that's
what you want to be my mistress he maybe
sounds a little whiny right now about
her not willing to keep him around when
she gets married but he's actually
confused because she basically promised
him that she'd be fine with keeping him
around back in the gift how long before
the king comes to claim my pillow don't
be ridiculous
my magic is mystical so you kind of got
a feel for the guy though what's funny
is Danny scene with Tyrion is actually
much more emotional and sweet how
quickly note that Danny wears black here
just like Cersei Elena and a number of
other characters this episode and black
does tend to signify death but also
power so it fits each character pretty
appropriately but this moment when she
makes tearing her hand it's extra
special for him because if you remember
back in the Battle of the Blackwater
Tyrion faced the same exact thing a
naval fleet trying to attack the city
and his clever thinking got them out of
it that time though Joffrey and Tywin
get all the credit and endearing is
actually stripped of his title of hand
of the king you are no longer hand of
the king for your trouble this time he's
appropriately rewarded and he's promoted
to that same title also the gift that
Dany is giving him the hand pen it's
actually a nice completion to the gift
that Dany gets back in that other
episode the gift
it's Tyrion Lannister I'm cute so they
really have developed a special
relationship here and it's kind of fun
to note her dad the Mad King he was
Aerys Targaryen and his hand was Tywin
Lannister now we have Daenerys Targaryen
and her hand Tyrion Lannister it seems
like another one of these cosmically
linked relationships in this series
let's get going
okay and now we're back at Winterfell
and it's interesting that Sansa stands
in the godswood and regarding the
warship that's done there she says tell
me little that all that is the same
religion that bran is pretty solid
evidence of being very legit a little
does she know actually that he can talk
to the past through
those same trees show some respect Sansa
but anyway this scene actually has a
parallel to a really long time ago the
pilot episode there also a stark sits at
a tree while someone else hopes that
they aren't interfering in that start
persons prayer to the old gods and in
that first episode it's about Catelyn
telling Ned that Jon Arryn is dead
Fievel took him and that's actually the
event that sets off this entire TV show
Catelyn suggests that Ned doesn't need
to go to King's Landing to take over the
role of hand of the king that Jon Arryn
had you can always say no matter but Ned
does anyway and we know how that turns
out in this episode though things are
actually flipped pretty consistently as
the outside person is Littlefinger and
instead of suggesting that the stark not
take the power he's pushing Sansa to
seek the power along with him a picture
of me on the Iron Throne thank you by my
side and Sansa says no to the suggestion
that she go after the power wall Ned
actually ended up going after it also
there's another link between these
scenes because the death of Jon Arryn it
wasn't a fever
it actually was a plot of little fingers
you gave me those drops and told me to
pour them into Jon's wine my husband's
wine you told me to write a letter to
cat telling her twas a Lannister
so in this grand plan that he laid out a
long time ago the Starks involvement it
did start at that tree and he's telling
the truth that all of his choices have
directly brought him closer to being at
Sansa side for now it's here back at
this symbolic tree though I bet he
probably didn't predict that it was
gonna be
Sansa that he was trying to convince to
join him I think he probably would have
imagined it would have been Catelyn who
was his first true love I've loved you
since I was a boy it seems to me that
fate has given us this last lost your
mind get up it's also worth
acknowledging Littlefinger's confession
here this is actually the first time
he's flat-out admitted he wants the Iron
Throne for himself and Sansa at his side
it all might be a play he assumed
Santa's gonna turn it down flat-out but
he wants to plant that idea in her head
because he knows it's gonna grow she's
gonna feel that it's her that deserves
to be the queen he wants her
pride to consume her as she sees John
get all the credit a little bit who
should the North rally behind true born
daughter of Ned and Catelyn Stark born
here at Winterfell where a motherless
bastard born in the south and being
Queen was santa's childhood dream except
it was with Joffrey of course so it
wasn't a great dream but Santa's still
maybe doesn't trust Littlefinger in this
moment but the idea that he's planted it
can still grow with time all right and
now we're arriving at the climax of the
episode and first this rule that benjin
teaches us about the wall and how the
magic keeps him from ever crossing it
again well it's not just ice and stone
ancient spells were carved into his
foundations strong magic to protect men
from us lies beyond that sounds a lot
like the magic that was previously
keeping the White Walkers away from the
great weirwood tree though now that bran
has the mark of the night king that
magic over there has fallen so does that
mean that if bran crosses the wall now
with a magic Fault there too it would
let the White Walkers finally walk into
the land of man it kind of does sound
like that's gonna happen right so it
basically does Brandi to cut his arm off
that's all I'm asking and just before we
jump into brains vision I'm gonna point
out that this weirwood tree that he's
about to see through it could maybe be
the same exact one that John once used
to take his Night's Watch vows they're
roughly the same exact place they have a
similar expression and the shape of
their main branches is the same the only
reason I even hesitate is that there are
a few minor differences but honestly I
feel like that's more an accident like
the show makers just couldn't get it to
be a perfect match and I'm actually
leaning toward this being the same exact
tree but okay into the vision and it's
the conclusion of our Tower of joy
scenes and there is so much to talk
about here it's very important to point
this out right now this reveal it's
technically the biggest reveal in the
entire story of Game of Thrones this is
the one thing people have been waiting
over 20 years to confirm and it's the
question that george RR martin used to
test the HBO show runners to see if they
were even true fans we had a 3-hour talk
at the very end of it George said okay
okay
who is Jon Snow's real mother and there
was a very long pause and I looked at
Dan and Dan looked at me and we threw
out a guess and kinda he didn't say yes
or no they sort of nodded and
then he let us take the show my point is
this true parentage of Jon Snow is huge
I have to point out in case it's still
not clear his mother is now officially
Lyanna Stark Ned Stark sister something
we did not know until this moment and
his father is definitely Rhaegar
Targaryen
Danny's older brother and son of the Mad
King and I know that yes they didn't
technically underline that Rhaegar was
his father but everything in the history
of this story has made it clear that
Liana was impregnated by Rhaegar who has
had her hidden in this tower and may be
the showrunners just wanted to save
talking about the Targaryen side of him
for next season but that is definitely
his father HBO even put out a graphic
after the episode to help clear it up
and while I understand that there are
those of you who are still a little
confused by it that is it's okay it's a
little hard to keep track of all these
things but the reason I'm emphasizing
this so much is there are people out
there a lot of them who still think that
Ned Stark is John's dad to think that
you would have to forget like again and
again all the explanations of how Ned
has been searching for his sister to
save her from Rhaegar and I don't know
like I guess I can't be too shocked
because Jaime and Cersei probably
confused that how a lot of people but
Ned is not his father Rhaegar is but
okay love let's get into specifics and
the first thing I want to point out in
the scene actually is when Ned turns
around this time bran hadn't shouted
anything brother
that actually confirms for us that when
Brandon appears in the past he changed
his time forever since he didn't shout
out and Ned still turned around it
wasn't him it was a different past
version of brand that made him turn
around so it seems like anything that
bran does in the past can never be
erased then when we're inside the room
I'm sure more than a few of you noticed
that the show really focused on the
sword being leaned against the bed well
that sword is Arthur Danes and if you
remember from when we talked about that
sword its name is dawn and supposedly it
was forged from the remains of a fallen
star that's significant because in the
azure Ahai prophecy about the prince I
was promised it says he was born
underneath a bleeding star so the sword
of the star and it's covered in blood
then does that count for the prophecy
maybe though it does seem like John was
born a few minutes before the sword got
placed there but still it feels like
this could count okay then let's
acknowledge that this is a huge secret
that's about to be created in this room
and Ned and Liana aren't the only people
there well that could explain another
secret of Ned's past you remember way
back in season one Ned is being asked by
Robert about this lady that he slept
with who supposedly is John's mother
must have been a rare wench to make Lord
Eddard Stark forget his honor
well Ned gives Robert a very specific
name and it's not Liana's obviously Lyla
Lyla well in the books Arya comes to
know House Dayne fairly well and that's
the same house of the night that was
guarding the tower outside Arthur Dayne
and Arya learns that house Dayne had a
servant named Wylla except she wasn't
just some servant she was specifically a
wet nurse for the Dayne babies so would
make a lot of sense if Ned has to make
up some lie about some woman he
supposedly fathered his baby with he
would just pick the name of one of the
women that was already there while a
servant of house Dayne who was brought
there by Arthur Dayne to care for this
woman and her baby and if you think
about it that lady does have to go on
and back up Ned's lie anyway so I
wouldn't be surprised if maybe they came
up with this bit of the story together
maybe as she was helping to tend to the
wounds of Meera and Jojen dad Howland
Reed who as far as we know is still just
waiting right outside
now until IANA and Ed's conversation it
was pretty hard to hear a lot of it but
one of the things that Liana definitely
says is this concern about Robert
killing a Targaryen baby explains why
Ned was so upset about Roberts plot to
kill Danny
knowing that Robert still cares that
much about wiping out the Targaryen line
all these years later means that John is
still in danger I'll kill every
Targaryen I get my hands on I want him
dead mother and child both then we're no
better than the Mad King she dies I will
have no part in it
also I know some of you thought Liana
meant Robert would kill Rhaegar but at
this point
Robert already had killed Rhaegar at the
Battle of the Trident and I think she
would know that but anyway Liana says
something else and it's much harder to
hear actually but it's also way juicier
referring to the baby she says
and then we don't hear the name at all
the one thing we can be pretty sure that
she doesn't say is John so does this
mean that John Snow has a secret
Targaryen name that we don't know about
yes it totally means that and that would
make sense because Targaryen have a very
unique naming scheme and if Ned kept his
Targaryen name everybody would know the
secret that he's a Targaryen as for what
the secret name could be well I see two
interesting options so let's trigger a
regular theory time to discuss what
these names could be okay so when I
watched it it looked to me like she was
saying a name that started with an a
sound which is pretty common in
Targaryen names Aerys Amon Aegon and
they often actually repeat names so
maybe from those exact names I just said
my pick would be Aegon in the house of
the undying Danny has all these visions
right but in the books it includes a
vision of her brother Rhaegar saying
that his son is probably the prince that
was promised and should be named Aegon
now the complication to this idea is
that Aegon is the name of the baby that
Rhaegar already had with his wife Elia
Martell who the mountain murdered you
might remember uh in the books that baby
was actually supposedly murdered by the
mountain and there's a lot more to his
story but it really seems like they're
not gonna do any of that story in the TV
show so if that's the case then I could
totally see them kind of merging it all
and borrowing that Aegon name for John
also if his name really is Aegon then we
get another nice payoff to a scene from
the gift in that episode maester aemon
is dying and if you remember Amon is a
Targaryen himself and on his deathbed he
encounters another baby and that baby
remind Damon of egg which is a nickname
for Aegon Targaryen
now that Aegon that he's talking about
is actually a man's little brother Aegon
v and grandfather of the Mad King and a
king himself in his own right and
maester aemon keeps lamenting that he
wasn't there for little baby Aegon and
he's upset that he didn't help raise his
own Targaryen blood but Amon did play a
huge role in helping raise Jon Snow
kills a boy
and let a man they pull
he's instrumental in his formation of
the leader so if jon snow's name really
is Aegon then it could be a nice poletik
link to amon sadly repeating mm-hmm
again and again these were some of his
last words and Amon would now be
properly honored because maybe he did
miss out on helping raise his little
brother Aegon a fifth but he was really
there for his great grand nephew Aegon -
six - garyun alone in the world
so terrible she okay so that's some
supporting reasons why his name could be
Aegon but let's take a look at another
option and this one is one a lip-reader
actually claims that they think they saw
Liana say that name is Jo Harris that's
a very old Targaryen name but it
actually has some positive traits
associated with it which is really rare
for Targaryen names by the way I this
King was known for being wise he ruled
for a long time and he expanded the
lands of the Nights Watch into what is
known as the new gift Jo Harris the
second was the mad Kings father - but
the best argument for why this name
could be Jo Harris was Jay Harris
Targaryen was the Targaryen who received
the prophecy about the prince that was
promised being born from their line it
actually caused him to get really
injured incest within targeting's
actually but anyway changing the name
from Jo Harris to Jon would respect that
J sound beginning and it also would let
Ned simply just say you know yeah I
named him after Jon Arryn the guy who
basically raised Ned so Jo Harris is
definitely an option - so let's go ahead
and jump out of theory time and wrap
things up before we fully move on though
I just want to point out a few last
interesting things here first we now
know that Jon's grandfather killed Jon's
other grandfather the Mad King is his
paternal grandfather who burned alive
Liyana Ned's father Rick art Stark next
don't you think that grown-up Lyanna
stark looks a lot like the red priestess
Kim bara like I can't say that they
definitely did this on purpose but
considering that we know that red
priestesses had the power to change
their appearance then convert could be
choosing to look like John's mom and
Daenerys is aunt Lyanna maybe okay and
finally remember when we talked about
the technical claim to the Iron Throne
earlier after Tommen and you could climb
upwards to the Baratheon line well when
we left off we were saying Robert
Baratheon brothers are all dead and his
parents are dead but his grandparents
Targaryen Roy L I think is her name her
dad actually was a ganda v who we
mentioned earlier so that's right Robert
is part Targaryen too or it was so if
you follow that Targaryen line back down
the rightful heir using the firstborn
son rules would be Jon Snow
but if Leon and Rhaegar were not married
which yes I get that Rhaegar was already
married to Elia Martell
but Targaryen did allow for polygamy but
yeah let's say they were not married
then John would still be a bastard which
means good old Daenerys Targaryen would
have the claim now funny enough though
if you go even further up Robert's
lineage you actually get to a Lannister
in there so yeah Robert was part
Targaryen and vaguely related to the
Lannisters the whole time and if you
followed that chain back down you would
get to either Jaime who now that he
isn't in the Kingsguard might have
claimed or Cersei but the greater point
to make here about claims in general is
clearly all these people have as much
legitimacy as any of the others do so
since there isn't a clear air this is
why wars happen at least in that
universe the true person who's finally
going to sit the throne it'll be the one
with the support of an army and the
people speaking of that let's move on to
the big declaration and Winterfell when
John becomes and look at John's art this
season he went from being not just
betrayed by his men but killed but dead
and now he's climbed all the way to king
of the north with a bunch of people
supporting him this meteoric rise of his
is actually foreshadowed in the gift by
a pretty surprising character Bastas can
rise high in the world like your
half-brother Jon Snow in this king of
the north moment is definitely a
storyline that is now further ahead than
the books arc but there's a fun
foreshadowing in the books where Lord
Commander Mormont has his raven that
speaks kind of like a parrot does and he
always seems to say things that have
like a little bit of extra meaning like
he actually says the word burn when Jon
is fighting that white and gives him the
idea to burn him at another time the
raven keeps staring at Jon and flat-out
keeps repeating the word
and it's barely a few lines later like
on that same page that John learns that
Rob has just been crowned king of the
north so that little section there
definitely feels like a big
foreshadowing at this moment okay and
since we are wrapping up this episode
I'm gonna start flying through some of
these miscible details first off and may
not have been clear but the man who does
not want to serve alongside the
wildlings the food aside with wildling
invaders that's Lord Royce he's the same
guy who's giving Littlefinger all that
trouble a couple episodes ago but he's
also now chanting king of the north a
few minutes later like the rest of
everyone is and he's the head of the
Knights of the Vale so once more he's
just being a big old thorn in a little
finger side also is fun to realize after
various men kneel to Jon and while that
chaining is going on torment just keeps
eating like it's not a sign of
disrespect actually it's a callback to
the fact that the wildlings they don't
kneel to any man south of the wall
oh and earlier when Lyanna stark tells
Ned who her baby is it means she's
revealing to him that this baby is in
line to be the rightful king of Westeros
and that's mirrored nicely here when her
namesake Lyanna Mormont declares that
jon is the rightful king here - that
said those same points I just made kind
of make this moment ironic as one of the
main reasons these people are behind Jon
is because he has that stops blood runs
through his veins well technically we
just found out no he doesn't though he
does have a starts blood in him oh by
the way if you're wondering if Jon Snow
is Jon Stark now actually he's not by
becoming King it actually doesn't matter
that he's a bastard he skipped this step
of being legitimized because the powers
of the North the heads of the households
they all declared him a king so he's an
actual bastard king now of course that's
not what they call him they call him the
white bull that's a bit of a callback to
how Robb Stark was known as the young
wolf and it also sounds like it could be
a reference to his wife direwolf ghost
but it's most likely Manderly
referencing Jon's new house sigil that
we'll see maybe eventually which I also
explained last episode it would be a
white wolf on a gray background also for
those of you that are looking for an
explanation of this back and forth look
from Sansa and Littlefinger it's tough
to know for sure and while I think that
it's purposely being left kind of open
the actress that plays Sansa said that
one she was playing that she was feeling
gel
C&M oh he's named King in the north and
she kind of gets no credit for it John
be so naive so chance is just a little
bit agitated to get to school and that
would imply that Santa is actually
realizing that Littlefinger may have
been right and maybe she thinks she
deserves that seat instead of John but I
like to think it's more complicated than
that and she's also worried about what
Littlefinger might be planning to do
that's kind of what I see in outlook
either way I'm not too worried for Khan
because like Danny he's won his crown
through loyalty and in an honorable way
and so that makes this coronation seem
very interesting to put back to back
with another coronation scene for the
queen of the south who has almost the
opposite circumstances you can see that
people hate Cersei and she does not have
their support and I do think we're
supposed to be comparing these two
situations right now because not only
are the scenes placed back-to-back but
they're also shot very similarly the
wide shots of fire lead to the crown
person and the person who's further
loyalty has become questionable moving
forward they're standing off to the side
also fun a note is that this new queen
she supposed to be heralded in by the
ringing of the Bell from the opening
images except she broke that bell and I
gotta say I don't think that's a good
sign for Cersei and I'm not just saying
that because of the looks of the people
it's look at Jamie I don't think she's
gonna sit on that Iron Throne very long
Jaime killed the Mad King for trying to
do the thing that Cersei actually did is
he gonna let her get away with that not
to mention she was indirectly
responsible for the death of his last
child and he did just come from an
encounter with his noble temptress
Brianne I think there's definitely some
real trouble brewing here between them
oh and also call out they brought back
in that amazing score from earlier but
now they mixed in the Lannister triumph
song the rains of castamere
but again House Lannister is not looking
too good right now though you know let's
acknowledge at least for this moment at
the end of season six here Cersei has
wand she actually had a very similar art
to John this season we left her at her
lowest low leading out of season five
and into this one and now she's climbed
all the way up and she's wearing and
brand new crown it's a pretty legit Ryze
definitely and if you remember yarn
Danny talked about how rare was for a
queen to rule in Westeros cuz the Iron
Islands ever had a queen before no more
than Westeros no sir she's beaten both
of them to it and what's interesting is
that she did in the way Danny had
planned to I'm not going to stop the
wheel I'm going to break the wheel but
Danny now with the guidance of Tyrion is
choosing to play the game you're in the
great game now they've traded places in
their approach but unfortunately for
Cersei I do not think her approach is
going to work when Danny gets there and
the famous prophecy that's now almost
complete with all her children dead
there's also a part about Cersei taking
the crown and then a younger more
beautiful Queen taking it away from her
now we all thought that was Marjorie and
I bet Cersei still thinks it's Margaery
but it definitely seems like it's
probably Daenerys actually and Cersei is
probably not gonna see any of this
coming
and since we're here let's go ahead and
talk about these closing shots beyond
gets a visual representation of the
season changing theme when the winds
indicate a new direction out with the
old and in with the new and by the way
I'll point out here that this season
changing it also happens to be happening
when the end of a television season is
changing as well so that's fun and since
we did it for John and Cersei we should
also point out Danny's similar arc this
season too she started in a lowest low
moment - you know down to nothing and
now she has behind her everything that
she's always wanted ships dragons a
massive army of different forces
including support from major families of
Westeros you can see sigils for the
Martel's
and for the Tyrell so she's closer to
her goals than she's ever been
and with this shot here of Dany finally
heading to Westeros her series long
promise is finally being paid off for
anything to point out here but I seen
when they were shooting it it was very
very cold and no one could think clearly
so Emilia Clarke the actress that plays
snares she told the director spotnik hey
I can't think clearly I have no idea
what I'm supposed to have in my head
while I'm staring off into the distance
and thinking about the future and he
gave her just one tip just one thing to
do and this is the take that they
actually ended up using he said just hum
the game of Thrones theme to yourself
and that's what she did that's what
she's doing right there in this shot I
think it kind of works actually and
continuing with this out with the old in
with the new theme it's interesting to
note how many of the important houses
are now led by women
the Targaryen the Lannisters the Starks
the Martel's the Tyrell the Greyjoy's
the more mods the knight queen okay I
made that one up but it's funny because
you just probably couldn't have guessed
this from the beginning when we were
watching that first episode there were
so many powerful men around then and
even our show's main hero felt like this
really good man but looking at it now
who's gonna win this whole thing
it's kind of like george RR martin is
saying to us who said anything about him
and with so many of these promises
finally being paid off john confirmed as
Rhaegar and Lyanna son arya finally
being a slick assassin who's taking
vengeance for her family Sansa is taking
back Winterfell
Theon is back with the Greyjoy's Circe's
on the throne bran is the Raven Jaime's
an effective commander and yeah Danny
with this fleet we now have a setup for
a brand new promise that there are gonna
be some amazing badass battles between a
lot of people who have a lot of power
all right so before we get to my
lingering questions I want to thank you
all for watching this season of
breakdowns of Game of Thrones go back
and watch any of the episodes you've
missed
there's know a lot of fun stuff that we
pointed out in them some crazy
predictions that somehow we got right
and some other stuff that we totally got
wrong but it's still probably fun to
take in and there's a lot of other good
analysis in there especially you have a
lot of time to wait before next season
and I want to give a special shout out
to our patreon supporters who are really
helping us put this content out and
they're also just helping us make other
content in general about Game of Thrones
and not Game of Thrones Marvel and Star
Wars stuff you can see a bunch of these
people's names in the description below
thank you so much to them they're making
all the difference specifically though I
got to give a shout out to my man Kenny
Smith one of our very first supporters
actually I want you to know that new
rock stars knows no Kenny but the Kenny
from patreon whose name is Smith and I
can't wait to talk creative stuff in our
upcoming Google hangout with Kenny and a
bunch of other people but all right on
to the questions okay first what do you
think John's real name is Aegon Joe
Harris Gary what is it let me know who
you think second is John going to find
out about his true parentage soon and if
so how Howland Reed is still out there
is brand gonna cross the wall maybe and
tell him and bring a bunch of white
walkers with him - oh you're secretly a
Targaryen also sorry I brought all these
white walkers with me I don't know maybe
third is Jaime gonna kill Cersei if not
how else are they gonna wrap their
storyline up it does not feel like
there's love there that's my opinion and
actually bonus question do you think
Daenerys and company are gonna make this
sea voyage unimpeded or are they gonna
run into trouble I think that they might
actually but I'm gonna save my idea for
season seven predictions video are
keeping a hell for that one it's coming
fairly soon as well as content about all
kinds of other stuff alright follow add
new rock stars on Twitter if you want to
talk about when videos are coming out
they have the answer to that and while I
don't know when the video will be posted
I do know other stuff so hit me up about
gamers
loans or other things you're curious
about on my Twitter at fimo or longer
stuff on my Facebook page facebook.com
slash fimo notes and in case you're
still wondering now you know two ways to
support us in making more of this
content one very directly you can sign
up to make ongoing contributions through
patreon or if you don't want to do that
that's fine you can share our videos
with your friends and help us expand our
audience
both of these are super helpful and very
much appreciated ok it's been a pleasure
I keep an eye out for our other content
my name is philip molina and i love you
all
I'll see you next time bye